peu
[Musique]
on prépare au cas les hélicoptères la
gendarmerie et vaut le voyage sans
histoire hong kong le coeur londres
paris puis le train anonymat complet
nous nous sommes retrouvés au point
contenu bien toi tu peut décoller ou
plus vite pour la prochaine livraison je
te fais signe comme d'habitude hockey
dans votre triangle vous est organisé
pour combien d'opérations simultanées
minimum 80 est assez de carburant pour
gagner le terminal 7000 km minimum mais
reste à savoir où est situé le terminal
ne serait qu'au dernier moment
normal ça va être le plus gros coup du
siècle jusque là motus
c'est un petit quelque chose non en tout
cas pas repéré par 2005
la région est truffé d'observateurs
étrangers
heureusement nous avons une couverture
de génie tu le feras disparaître comme
les autres et c où le pc la aux alibis
de notre présence pas d'alibi le retour
à la nature la pêche à la ligne et le
phare nyamba mérité à moi je suis censé
être un bourgeois ayant fait fortune
dans l'import export et les techniciens
se font passer pour les ouvriers qui
retape la baraque quand le coût sera
réussi la surprise n'en sera que plus
grande pour ces braves gens des villages
alentour et aussi pour certains chefs
d'état une petite cinquantaine au
minimum allons-y
[Musique]
on
la connexion de base mis dans le sommes
portés acquéreurs alors demain vous
voulez déballerai qu'après mon tour pour
les gravures du xviie
la réponse de l'académie impériale
médard de tokyo est arrivé pas encore
monsieur mais j'ai une communication hac
attaché culturel de l'ambassade
japonaise l'acceptation principes et
obtenu le stoïcien pour avoir lieu au
mois de décembre
bon de votre côté à notre domicile
bon alors pendant mon absence vous
expliquerai les avait un courant et ben
s'il ya quoi que ce soit selon johanne
de monsieur demain et après demain à
bord de votre bateau à cannes
vous l'avez pas oublier l'indicatif
radio car 28 56 87 la marine nationale
ça vous n'êtes vraiment pas en fait je
ne sais pas ce que je sois sans vous
ensuite pendant quinze jours je serai
basés en crète
je m'amuserai faire quelques photos g
lors de l'idf est ce le consommateur
villa à booster téléphone 37 à kandy
admirable les dames et ramenez vous
attend
puis dix minutes et l'avion pendant une
heure les enfants sont déjà prêts et pas
simplement excité visite
ces messieurs télévision sont là et vous
attendent pas l'interview nom d'un chien
et je vais tout de suite j'espère qu'ils
n'en ont pas trop longtemps
bon bah bonjour les enfants ou des
jeunes et sans moi une dernière corvée
ensuite au lendemain oui sans inquiétude
les vacances c'est sacré au moins
d'impôts à l'état
monsieur le conservateur vous êtes un
des plus célèbres orientaliste français
vous êtes également le directeur de ce
musée un des plus beaux du monde hors
guerre vous avez été élu à l'unanimité
fait rarissime membre de l'institut au
titre de l'académie des inscriptions et
belles lettres
quelles sont vos réactions je n'avais
aucune
bien entendu je suis très flatté de
l'honneur qui vient le maître fait vous
avez vécu longtemps en extrême-orient
aux 20 ans de ma vie
tandis en chine et 5 au japon c'est
justement là où il faudra en venir
tout le monde admet que vous êtes un
savant éminent mais on laisse également
entendre que vous avez joué un rôle
disant politique dans cette partie du
monde
voilà ce qui s'appelle la question piège
oui mais c'est en étude alors ouais je
vous demandais de la formule est plus
directement je verrai si je peux vous
répondre
disons que dans les milieux
gouvernementaux internationaux
on a plutôt tendance à vous connaître
sous le pseudonyme de l'empereur oui ça
c'est ridicule mais c'est exact on
laisse entendre également que vous
auriez participé à de nombreuses
conversations diplomatiques
sinon clandestinement du moins d'une
façon officieuse
y at-il un lien commun entre ce
personnage appelé l' empereur et l'homme
éminent le savant membre de l'institut
auquel je m'adresse aujourd'hui à part
ça je peux vous répondre franchement
l'empereur est mort depuis dix ans je ne
m'intéresse plus qu'à l'art sous toutes
ses formes
est-ce que les arts martiaux c'est une
forme d'art qui vous intéressent
particulièrement
au cours de ma vie et de mes aventures
passées se dit bien passé j'ai appris à
mépriser et ail la violence sous toutes
ses formes
je trouve que l'homme n'est pas fait
pour se battre et je considère les armes
comme des crimes que les armes sont
quelquefois utile au moins pour se
défendre
les choeurs devrait suffire les
rivalités des hommes comme celle des
empires sont sordides
le seul vrai courage c'est celui qui
établit la paix et la protège qu'il
s'agisse de la vie quotidienne plus
humble des êtres ou de ce que les
imbéciles et les ambitieux appelle les
grands événements de l'histoire du monde
dans ce cas monsieur conservateur je
pense que groupe et qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qu'il ya approchant pour vous
messieurs vous permettez et les un
orphelin je vous demande dix minutes
non
non honnêtement je ne peux pas accepter
vous allez et combien je suis attaché
votre mouvement et le respect que je
porte à votre oeuvre scientifique
comment votre action morale en faveur de
la paix mais celui qu'on appelait
l'enfant est mort il ya dix ans j'ai
bien encore de le répéter il n'y a pas
ça milite au journaliste de la
télévision il n'est pas question que je
reprenne du service
c'est toujours dans la force de l'âge et
nul ne connaît le monde vous justement y
en a je ne les connaît que trop
toutes ces petites guerres de se bâtir
leur nom n'évoque ton mois que du dégoût
chips bande du cinéma pour moi tout ça
c'est fini je ne m'intéresse plus qu'à
la paix et à mes enfants est un art très
bien très bien parlons plus disons alors
j'ai un service personnel à vous demande
ça c'est différent je peux
ce visage là vous dit quelque chose
joliment dimitri au bled chef des
services secrets du pacte de sofia on a
retrouvé son cadavre il y a huit jours
une balle en pleine poitrine dans un
event cévenol et faisait de la
spéléologie
non non sa spécialité c'est l
aéronautique
celui-ci vous le connaissez pour le
voltage tir en bocaux soma délégué de la
force centrafrique le gendarmerie locale
le retrouver il ya 48 heures sous un
chêne liège à 500 m de la grotte où on a
trouvé oblet miss qui faisait la sieste
ah oui oui mais alors avec un poignard
entre les deux épaules le décès
remontant à quatre jours
les corbeaux avaient commencé leur
travail celui-ci plutôt le petit
parisien
on ne peut pas dire plus on va vous
allez visé juste c'est un agent des
services spéciaux français mort comme un
ami les pas avoir du tout ils se
promènent même en ce moment dans la
région
celui-ci non erwin bartenschlager agents
de renseignement de l'allemagne de l'est
il est spécialisé dans les
télécommunications il est toujours
vivant lui aussi il se promène aussi
dans la région elle c'est chic italie
figurait dans une aventurière
brésilienne qu'on dit très proche des
milieux gouvernementaux et elle se
promène aussi dans le secteur
oui ah ouais ça c'est la wii
je connais même je peux vous dire que je
suis sûr qu'il est sur la piste de la
belle brésilienne vrai nom georges nos
multiples matricule 3.3 quelque chose
brillant chasseur d'homme
d'outre-atlantique un seul défaut chasse
également les dames pendant les
entractes
mais dites moi toute cette collection de
mort et de vivant s'allume à quoi vous
devinez bien qu'ils travaillent tous
pour leurs gouvernements respectifs
oui sans doute certains pour plusieurs
mais qu'est ce qu'il fabrique dans les
grottes du sud est de la france
nous y voilà effectivement ils font
partie avec des gens moins dangereux
plus d'une prétendue mission
archéologique international qui
recherchent la couronne d'attila vous
savez ce fabuleux trésor qui aurait été
enfouis au xième siècle par le dernier
survivant de à des baumes il suivi moyen
ces agents ne sont de la pop rien ils
sont là en observateurs pour quelque
chose de grave
quelque chose de grave que notre
mouvement le tient pas ce qu'il
communique alors gouvernement oui nous
revoilà sa taille secrets de la guerre
bactériologique sans doute
sans doute pas la mission archéologique
recherche la couronne d'attila dont le
gouffre calcaire baptisé gouffre de dour
bilan vous savez celui qu il est
interdit d' explorer à cause du siphon à
la cote -6 112 cm sommes dès samedi
quelque chose ah bah oui oui je me
souviens maintenant trois explorateurs
noyer il ya 5 6 ans c'est exact ça n'est
pas la vraie raison
la véritable raison de l'interdiction
ce sont les échantillons de gaz
exactement quatre mises au point par nos
chercheurs et qui représentent des
dangers mortels en cas de guerre ces
échantillons sont dans les containers
qui repose à la cote moins 2000 mais ses
agents dont vous m'avez montré les
photos seraient là pour mettre la main
dessus
oui c'est ce que nous avons pensé
d'abord mais nous sommes sans doute
trompé la mort parce que perso non
or nul ne sait où sont enfouis ces
containers ensuite ensuite
savez vous qui a organisé et qui dirige
cette prétendue mission archéologique
nom changera gore
jean bart goor celui de l'association
des frères de cali l'assassin mondial
numéro 1 celui des génocides
celui qui finance la mafia et le
terrorisme
[Musique]
enfin disons plus simplement
celui qui veut la peau de votre frère il
ya cinq ans quand une bombe a explosé
dans la soute à bagages du paris dakar
[Musique]
me donne vous demandez quoi je me
demande moi je vais annoncer à ma
famille à mes enfants
il embarque seul pour la craie et que
j'irai me rejoindre plus tard la réponse
est oui comme on dit je monte sur le
coup vos calculs étaient erronées mais
ce charrues cette excavation avec une
impasse vous dites sur d'un monsieur
rétiaire darty que votre théorie sur
l'orientation de la galerie d'entrée
était fausse monsieur charrues ce que je
savais depuis le premier jour plus je ne
vous plaît pas de critiquer côté
messieurs louise charrues je suis un
savant envoyé par la rosa luxemburg
musée on dépeint cov et l'institute de
spéléologie de leipzig
je participe à cette mission
internationale de façon officielle je
l'étais voire de contribuer à retrouver
sous l'autorité du chant dragor la
couronne d'attila je constate simplement
que tous ceux qui crient dans votre
livre sur ces sujets est absolument faux
monsieur le livre de mon mari a été tiré
à 300 mille exemples et si nous
attaquions pour la galerie ouest
non non mon avis c'est très dangereux la
pique est d'au moins 1000 pieds bas il
n'ya qu'à se procurer les cordages de
rappel en nylon moi je suis léger je
suis prêt à prendre le risque de
décembre qu'est ce que vous en pensez si
renard
dis toi monsieur van hover strates
puisque c'est vous notre intendant et
notre comptable une telle acquisition
nous reviendra combien
c'est l'ordre de 5 à 6 francs m x 1000
mètres x 2 pour le rappelle c'est de
l'ordre d'un million combien en
reste-t-il en caisse c'est le calcul sur
la possession des équipes ça c'est les
pommes de terre
[Applaudissements]
ah voilà les comptes
voyons il doit rester à la banque 890
dollars un peu plus de quatre cent mille
anciens francs et le prochain versement
de 5000 $ et pour quand pour dans vie
dans quinze jours dans quinze jours la
rivière souterraine aura grossi et le
saas ne sera plus franchissable malik
prépare ma nourriture
puisqu'il faut que la pure soit la base
du pur afin que le pur reste
y a qu'à lever novateurs comme attac un
salam sandra saïb je romps spa en signe
d'espoir en priant les forces terrestres
ne pas s'imposer plus longtemps à nos
recherches
[Musique]
je
donnez moi je vous dis ronger messieurs
mais d'un léger dois m'entretenir
d'urgence avec monsieur chandran gore
c'est moi
on vous aime bien monsieur le le chef de
mission archéologique internationale qui
explore le gouffre des dirigeants afin
de retrouver la couronne dakhil oui que
désirez-vous le marchand jean le
marchand professeur d'enseignement livre
à limoges spécialiste de l'archéologie
clinique est membre de plusieurs
sociétés régionales monsieur gendre
accord monsieur chandra gorge
il faut que vous ne vivez vous j'ai la
solution
je sais où où se trouve la couronne
d'attila aux entrants thierry courantes
at il a le plus fabuleux trésors du
monde arraché à l'inde du 1er siècle te
regarde regarde heureux gardiez
nous sommes ici leur l'erreur c'est de
vouloir pénétrer par le gouffre actuelle
il ya eu un éboulement au viiie siècle
avant la porte et elle est là là là
c'est la fameuse galerie oblique de 300
coups dont on parle dans le manuscrit de
mayence elle donne directement sur un
escalier intérieur de 7777 marche qui
contourne à la pique de 300 m là vous
voyez à l'intérieur de la paroi
mais comment avez vous déterminez
l'autre est bouchée par l'éboulement là
et là dans lacunes abl dit de clément 3
la troisième unis dix huitième mois la
lune se lèvera à lorient de nydus sur le
mont du septentrion et son rayon viendra
frapper la porte d'or
il donne sur la nuit mais le huitième
mois c'est le mois d'août
nous sommes en octobre non auto 8,8 en
latin le huitième mois 7 octobre
apprennent la couronne et chanterait
genre peut être à nous mais où trouver
l'argent nécessaire aux forages
toutes mes économies 3 million
d'anciennes je les met à votre
disposition
je vous en prie acceptez mois 3 500 vous
êtes de l'autre je dois vous présenter
nos collègues de la mission d'abord ou
qu'à mon meilleur ami balik mon
secrétaire barak mon serviteur monsieur
louis charrues le célèbre auteur du
livre les cent mille trésors de la terre
adam charrues chiquita deux figures et
donc de la recherche archéologique
brésilienne georges schmit qui travaille
pour l'american technique à la gt
l'institute monsieur pilotin
journalistes à la corrèze républicaine
et qui fait une enquête sur notre
expédition et vanover sera secrétaire de
notre expédition
bon ben je crois que le plus urgent mais
maintenant que vous alliez vous cherchez
un équipement complet de spéléo au bourg
voisin vous ne pouvez pas descendre vers
le gouffre avec cette tenue dans dans le
voyage au centre de la terre jules verne
ne faisait bien descendre ses héros en
la vie en jaquette
peut-être que vous pourriez utiliser mon
argent d'une façon positive
nous ne faisons pas du jules verne nous
opérons avec méthode
il ya plusieurs lacs souterrains qu'il
faut franchir est leur passage est
difficile il est préférable que vous
équipiers
j'y vais j'y vais être une suite les
accompagnent c'est cela ça nous fera
gagner du temps professeur vous
permettrait que j'examine aux documents
pendant votre absence rien ne me ferait
plus plaisir
henry ils sont là pour ça je vous laisse
je suis sûr que les renseignements du
professeur le marchand confirmeront les
miens et que l'entrée indiqué par lui
nous conduira tout droit aux grands
couloirs de l'existence
quelle je n'ai jamais douté ainsi que je
les écris à la page 2 175 de mon ouvrage
275 et 276 avec en notre référence aux
pics darboux ce dont a parlé le
professeur par ses traders
or a bonne mine crois moi cet imbécile
des bartenschlager le sait déjà
il a bonne mine non mais qu'est-ce qui
se croit celui là en tout cas il a
préféré sortir et la discussion on du
vent dans ce qu'il ya du vent et ça veut
nous donner des leçons
non mais vous demande un peu moi à sa
place je reprendrai le premier train
pour berlin est et ouest je m'en fous
pas au vu du parc avec des bons temps
café poule
c'est un bon cheval vous êtes là
[Musique]
la valeur est à ses quelque chose vous
inquiète-t-il
non y'a je voulais montrer les documents
de la marche en ardenne schlager mais il
a dû aller se promener c'est pas grave
puis-je examiné ses documents bien sûr
merci
[Musique]
malik la calado
un cas que se passe-t-il
j'avais besoin d'herbes sauvages pour
mon repas sacré de demain alors je les
aurais dit les chercher nous examinons
les plans mais bien sûr je sommes en
train d'examiner les plans de marchands
vous vous joignez vous à nous non je
vous remercie
je m'en vais faire quelques croquis par
là où cela me détendre à je serai de
retour dans une petite heure on ne
serait pas parti pour le gouffre non non
nous attendons le professeur de limoges
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons regarder cela avec vous ah
mais je vous en prie j'ai ainsi pas de
mauvais conseil avec ce que tu sais je
me demande d'ailleurs tu vas chercher
tout ça ce que lui disent je disais que
c'est l'expédition retrouver la couronne
d'attila ce serait pour moi un reportage
du siècle et je parle pas seulement de
l'accord et républicaine mais la radio
la télé et tout quoi et il y a longtemps
que vous êtes à la corrèze le public
s'attend à ce que les chiens écrasés
mais les plus grands journalistes ont
commencé comme ça et qu'est ce qui vous
a branché sur l'expédition à la
recherche de la couronne bêtes là c'est
mon patron il est dingue de ces trucs là
et ça vous pousse à vous y croyez moore
vous savez que d'après le manuscrit de
maillot sur lequel je me suis fondé pour
mes travaux
le trésor qui est avec la couronne
peut-être d'aliens pas loin d'un
milliard de nouveaux francs c'est à dire
100 milliards d'anciens francs
moi je suis payé 80 centimes la ligne et
à la pige encore et est ce que vous
pensez du chef de l'expédition
c'est un cinglé l'insuline offensif avec
ses serviteurs et seychelles fait de la
mise en scène mais ça va pas plus loin
et c'est l'argent il a des rêves je
crois pas à mon avis c'est un mystique
linguistique entre tous
je ne sais pas quoi ils jouent en tout
cas ils jouent pour pas grand chose
mais dites moi il n'y avait pas deux
autres membres si de l'expédition qui
ont disparus disparus n'ont ils en ont
eu marre de la couronne se sentirait
tout simplement
il y avait le russe au volant ce qui la
fait qu'un bateau se marre mais disons
non humains alors ils ont jeté l'épongé
à trois jours d'intervalle et en prenant
si j'avais pas des articles à faire
quand et si la bonne soupe
j'en aurai marre aussi la couronne mais
pourquoi avez vous dit
disparu s'ils avaient disparu ou si leur
était arrivé quelque chose ça se serait
su on aurait eu la jambe d'un bris sur
dos ce côté là rien les trois
professeurs ont posé des questions à
mystic route
e
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
on
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alimentation sur piles 24 volts porter
50 m rayon 15 degrés comme vous le voyez
pour les courtes distances ici vous avez
le foyer réglable avec le casque 90
francs
faites-le conduite de monsieur alors
nous avons 600 mètres de cordage mille
entrées ses qualités a garanti ensemble
caoutchouc avec bottes assorties
survêtement combinés et les genouillères
de ce seuil et le casque également ci
dessous
son souci troufions la médaille en sens
interdit en plus que ce qu'il a approuvé
la à lui samedi de mobiliser cette ue
sais rien je connaissais au fond nous
allons passer de plus serré pourquoi de
groningue on bute madame qu est-ce qu
dior nous n'avons pas talonner alors
nous peu snob ruban leur boîte et les
oreilles pour l'apprendre à savoir
conduire les domaines des jamais fait
dérouiller pour la conséquence du temps
d'enlever sa casquette quand il n'est
pas là bien madame madame mail tout
votre chapeau pas à sa bonne place
madame heures tu te fous de ma gueule
tableau que nous sommes pressés qui
chantait en étranger en plus corte
ingles most on cherche chaque geste le
toit à la bagarre merde encore une
gonzesse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
23/10 pas d'histoire en histoire folle
histoire en palestine
[Musique]
à
oh
soit
non
cet homme on y va l'autre à oman qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
nous vivons une drôle d'époque phénicie
passe rock america est élevé chez les
bons repères ça va tourner au vinaigre
on y va
[Musique]
t
moi non
[Musique]
e
oh
vos papiers
vous êtes anglaise votre profession
n'est pas marqué qu'est ce que vous
faites
je sais capitiens dans l'encours vous
foutez de moi
je dois reconnaître que c'est vrai mais
c'est inattendu au ps francis possède
les chantiers royaux de potes 3000
tonnes de bidonnage par an l'enfer band
est une infamie quoi alors moi je
conteste je suis pour la marine en bois
la vraie celle de drake de winter de
tourville on est romantique on est
réaliste j'ai filé sur marseille voici
ma lettre d'engagement je suis embauché
pour commander le cible une goélette de
340 tonneau que possède le fameux
armateurs grecs mix la qds et madame et
votre second madame et mademoiselle au
pardon mademoiselle et votre seconde
mademoiselle et ma femme de chambre je
rêve sans doute mais depuis crécy
azincourt il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses
acceptons-en l'évidence vous je vous
connais vous appartenez à l'expédition
spéléo du gouffre du dos bilan exact
qu'est ce que vous foutez danse et
rigole j'étais dans le magasin enfin
gilles vie de madame été attaqué alors
c'est comme ça c'est pas vrai a conduit
à créer une fois charles est en plein
sens interdits en plus vous parlerez que
quand je vous interrogerait et vous vous
faisiez quoi lui fait partie de
l'expédition depuis aujourd'hui c'est
lui qui sait tout sur le manuscrit de
mayence sur l'incunable dit degrémont 3
sur le mont du septentrion sur la
galerie oblique sur la troisième nuit du
8ème mois du calendrier julien
pour vous dire il sait de quoi il cause
vos papiers genre le marchand professeur
d'enseignement livre à limoges
spécialiste de l'archéologie unique je
sais tout sur la couronne d'athina et
sur le journal de frisco ambassadeurs de
byzance chargé de limiter les dégâts je
ne vous en demande pas tant
pardonnez moi monsieur le professeur
j'ai besoin de témoins qu'est ce qui
s'est passé est mienne
nous sommes simplement venir au secours
de mademoiselle qui était lâchement
attaqué celle là a conduit là comme une
dingue et à gauche en plus ample un sens
interdit
mais vous vous travaillez où on
travaille au château de marque acer ont
construit quoi on n'est pas capitaine au
long cours ou archéo truc alors qu'on
nous laisse vous l'année c'est tout ce
qu'on demande alors tous demain matin à
10h à mon bureau pour le procès verbal
est entre-temps recommencer par un
non-lieu souvenir de 2 gigas schricke
j'étais élève avant d'être professeur et
vous ceinture rouge 3e dan
où allez vous chercher ça moi j'ai vu ça
toute ma vie au cinéma alors c'est tout
comme et vous ça attire marron et 3e dan
maillot j'ai commandé une jonque l'année
dernière pendant six mois
alors comme il n'y avait pas de vent je
m'ennuyais j'ai regardé l'équipage
s'amuser c'est vraiment ma femme de
chambre et pas la peine de vous donner
tous mal pour fabriquer votre personnage
je sais qui vous êtes et comment qui
suit vous êtes l'empereur je ne sais pas
pourquoi a sans doute parce que je parle
toujours de justinien en fait c'était
[Rires]
pas celui là l'empereur le vrai le
patron enfin l'ex patron des services
spéciaux en extrême orient
l'homme de la détente avec la chine
shanghai phong le seul membre blanc du
kung fu la tuerie est bon moi je met
cartes sur table je m'appelle jacques
piloter et je suis agent des services
d'études et de recherches de sécurité
françaises mais j'ai eu du flair c'est
pour ça qu'on met sur des coûts
marginaux comme la couronne date il en
est hors sujet tout à l'heure vous
m'avez posé tout un tas de questions sur
les membres de l'expédition
je crois je vous ai répondu à peu près
le contraire de ce que je pensais je
veux être loyal gage de mon désir de
collaboration avec vous un champ dragor
mystère pas sur sa personne puisque sur
ce qu'il vient faire dans ce patelin
perdu mali khaimah rak ce sont ses
gardes du corps
mais louis charrues à passer par profits
et pertes
elle a une famille tricotée lui c'est un
malin qui touche des droits d'auteur en
inventant des histoires sur l'atlantide
mont venteux finistère quoi
chiquita défiguré dont elle travaille
pour les services secrets brésilien jean
schmitt pour les américains n'empêche la
geurre pour l'allemagne de l'est
mais bon le strat pour l'irlande il
avait une telle imagination suffit latin
et si j'ajoute qu'au volant ski qui
travaillait pour les services secrets
soviétiques et ben cosma qui travaille
pour le service secret africains se sont
également faits décembre preuve que la
gendarmerie a aussi dans l'ordre de de
se taire de maintenir black out de
mettre les cadavres frais tous fils au
tac que je suis je sais de quoi je parle
vous avez raison mon vieux
je suis lampre je suis la forme occuper
le champ dragor je vous proposais
collaborer avec moi c'est déjà accepté
je me demande simplement quel est le
prochain qui va tomber
[Musique]
terminé
bonjour moyens et bonne route
voyages et des routines ils sont tous là
tous risques à cannes aussi hausse il
est arrivé hier pour six voyages nous
avions 10 6 millions exact tu connais
nos conventions le silence ou la fraude
pylônes mal placé t'as combien d'enfants
3-1 gardent leur impair
tu peux filet
[Musique]
jusqu'à cannes est prêt il ya d'anti
combien d'opérations simultanées
je trouve ça n'est pas mal jean garantie
sauvé ça fait de sa et
les américains sont madrid les européens
81 2 400 au total les neuf dixièmes de
la flotte aérienne au long cours
autrement dit la paralysie totale de
l'économie mondiale à côté de cet
exploit
tout le reste c'est du petit artisanat
et en profiter
[Musique]
du côté terminal tout est paré nous
avons payé des spécialistes à prix d'or
il n'y aura ni embouteillages ni
catastrophe et notre génial amis le
timing détermine son arrivée vous
arrivez h - 48
il sera là - 24 bat d'observateurs
indiscrets pas trop les deux seuls que
nous avons repéré au bol ans qui
travaillait pour les ruches et beau
kassoma qui travaillait pour les
africains ont terminé accidentellement
leurs jours dans cette région charmante
des enquêtes et non ce pays est celui de
la bête du gévaudan les morts
accidentelles sont considéré
traditionnellement comme naturelle
[Musique]
alors monsieur le professeur procédant à
ce premier repérage
si votre disposition ça nous fera gagner
du temps pour demain une fois
l'ouverture déterminer si vous avez
raison il ne nous restera plus qu'à
attendre la confirmation dites de la
troisième nuit du 8ème mois
je précise si toutefois vous avez raison
les raisons je viens avec vous je vois
déjà le titre dont le journal couronne
d'attila le cird archamps dragor le
professeur le marchand la science
occidentale rejoint l'intuition
orientale et une photo en première page
pour force 8 pouces par georges frêche
soirée
vous voulez venir faire une promenade
avec moi bien sûr petite princesse et
vers où nous dirigeons nous
où vous voudrez georges
topo phare à la blague qui se cache à
saint maurice et c'est que l'automne on
sait pas bien ce qui lui a fait écouter
madame charrues je suis en train de
calculer
l'affluence de la déclination de
l'écliptique par rapport au point vernal
à l'époque de la ivème dynastie
alors vous pensez c'est ce qui vous
préoccupe je m'en tape la vulgarité mais
qui tarde qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'espère georges vous êtes à cette
personne que je puisse me confier il
faut que je me protège et sinon je vais
mourir comme les autres quel autre on
peut les skins évoqué ce moment disparu
et bâton je suis un gars est mort qu'est
ce que vous me racontez il ya deux
heures bartoli shaggy tête ici parmi
nous tuer mais je vais vous montrer ça
me montrer quoi son cadavre
là juste à l'entrée de la grande caverne
venez le temps presse alors où est il je
ne comprends pas quitter la lie à une
demi heure avec un couteau entre les
épaules
nous sommes surveillés continue en juin
dès que nous serons rentrés au camp venu
voir sous la tente
la situation est grave mariani gras
vient d'arriver et en 48 heures ce sera
le coup d'éclat le plus fantastique de
ce siècle
tu laisses moi je vais vous aider ce
soir c'est ma tante
dès que la nuit sera tombée d'accord
prenez ma part la taille
nous observe
l'édition spéciale sur un point pour ce
soir c'est le marchand votre théorie
était séduisante mais je dois
reconnaître qu'elle ne nous a rien
apporté à roman mais je suis sûr de mon
fait je reprendrai mes calculs cette
nuit à partir du point fixe et
constituant le clip darmouth et
déterminerait exactement l'emplacement
de la porte de rats devant la troisième
nuit à votre guise
mais nous nous reprendrons l'expédition
au point fixe et par monsieur charrues
enfin on rend justice c'est pas coupe
vous me range khalid hâtivement que je
les ai confié mais certainement malick
ba baca va car thibault yaka said bakar
j'ai dit ah
chiquita
la trousse de premier secours
j'ai quitté dans le coma son qui revient
de lâcher il faut aller chercher une
ambulance un médecin c'est une question
de quart d'heure elle est morte
voilà gala cheater calais
l es chez toi gardez la toute-puissante
divinités noires que personne ne touche
à rien je reviendrai avec un médecin
j'exige une autopsie
cette mort est suspecte c'est un crime
les paupières bleuâtre à la base les
arcades sourcilières ne trompe pas elle
été empoisonnée qui me signale toute
personne qui s'éloigne du campo lomme en
l'absence dans des chaudrons
inutile d'y aller par quatre chemins
vous travaillez pour l'intelligence
service mois actuellement pour un
service américain hello deux
organisations des rapports de
coopération non vous permettez
d'ailleurs j'avais pour instruction
d'entrer en contact avec vous mais
j'aurais préféré le faire d'une façon
plus discrète et moins improvisées mais
les choses se précipitent g chandra
gants dans le collimateur comme vous
certainement d'ailleurs mais il est très
habile et je n'ai encore rien découvert
seulement voilà un crime vient d'être
commis dans le camp et la personne qui
vient d'être tu étais la seule est trop
compte quelque chose elle voulait me
faire des révélations mais n'a pas eu le
temps de parler alors je vous propose de
mettre nos renseignements en commun
qu'en pensez vous
que savez-vous
avant de vous répondre
bonne question mais que français que
j'ai rencontré sur la place valeur le
petit journal est le pion mal rasé qui
est ce une question avant de vous
réponds pourquoi me demandez-vous cela
est bien parce que je te laisse la place
ils ont fait une brillante démonstration
de karaté ce sont de super champion
meloni alors qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire eh bien le petit journal où c'est
le capitaine jacques pilote un agent du
service des études et recherches de la
sécurité française
il fait ici ce que nous faisons tous il
observe quant à l'autre le pion mal rasé
comme vous dites vraiment je ne sais pas
qui c'est et maintenant que savez-vous
et bien il y a 6 ans les autorités
françaises ont enfoui dans le golfe du
morbihan
des conteneurs renfermant un gaz mortel
l'exacte 1,4 je suis certain nous sommes
certains que chambres accor sous le
prétexte de la petite expédition qui la
montée est à la recherche des conteneurs
il veut mettre la main dessus pour les
revendre à prix d'or à une petite
puissance du moyen-orient
soyons sérieux son expédition en hormis
les agents étrangers qui sont tombés
comme des mouches
vous pilotez un mois et peut-être ceux
qui ont mal rasé est composé de pieds
nickelés qui ne rêve que de l'atlantide
annonce n'est pas avec tout et le tocard
qu'il va aboutir
oui mais c'est tout cas ça ne sont qu'un
alibi sa véritable équipe ne pas essayer
et watten elle est au château de
makassar et bien si nous y allions faire
un tour j'allais vous le proposer mais
comme je ne me suis pas habillé pour ce
genre de petites sorties nocturnes
je vais me changeait pas d'objection
[Musique]
où
[Rires]
colère de rigolos vos conspirateurs le
pato est un marché en dessous prennent
aux as et ses acolytes prétendent qu'ils
sont des ouvriers qui retape la maison
la marchande souple ou terroristes
allons y gaiement
[Musique]
on est transporté là où vous savez donc
le pré 2 nous avons repris connaissance
cela permettra de faire de la mienne pas
pour longtemps je crois
jean sweat et méfiant mais il connaît
son métier il a foncé tête baissée sur
une piste mais avant il a pris une
contre assurances devez savoir sans
doute qui je suis en réalité j'ai trouvé
ça dans mon sac de couchage
ça doit vouloir dire quelque chose mais
je comprends pas entre l'europe et le
grand large
l'angleterre choisira toujours le grand
large signé churchill quoi moi je vois
je vois pas ce que ça veut dire
moi si schmidt travail pour les
américains et la cia
le capitaine au long cours en face aux
dealers
la petite anglaise d'hier de toute
évidence appartient aux services
spéciaux anglais elle est descendue à
mon vaillant ici alors on y va et en
vitesse non compris monsieur ayoubi mix
plat newsletters ceci chaque fils autant
personnelle et celle est pour moi si
monsieur la voici merci
la couronne d'attila c'est trop sans
doute à makassar signé un ami qui vous
veut du bien de les raisons on y va oui
on pourra la porte quelques précautions
parce que la partie risque d'être rude
[Musique]
un proverbe de chez moi dit c'est pas
son intelligence que l'intelligent
comprend pourquoi l'imbécile réussi
amener là où se trouvent déjà les autres
offrent un blu du tout cinq caméras du
béton et
écoutez moi bien tout ce qu'un médecin
plus qu'à 24 heures de la minute 0 vous
savez ce que vous avez à faire
je peux vous garantir que vous serez en
mesure de le faire pour plusieurs
raisons
avec la fausse expédition de la couronne
date il là j'ai pu faire abcès de
fixation
les agents des grandes puissances sont
tous tombés dans le panneau
trois d'entre eux sont morts est les
quatre survivants sont actuellement nos
prisonniers grâce et je le remercie à
isques à caen dans une demi heure ils
seront morts mais passons aux choses
sérieuses là se trouve la mire à de
caspar est il dispose d'une piste
colossal installés par les américains en
1943 et permettant l'atterrissage d'un
appareil toutes les deux minutes
comme nous allons détourné simultanément
400g intercontinentaux cela prendra au
total 800 minutes en moins de 13 heures
l'opération sera terminée et nous
disposerons alors de plus de 40 mille
prisonniers de toutes nationalités
l'émir de caspar est un représentant à
l'onu
c'est lui qui discutera au sommet la vie
sauve pour les prisonniers
hélas non destruction des 400 jette
contre l'abandon de toute participation
financière et l'évacuation de toutes les
bases contrôlé par les américains du
nord
les européens les chinois et les russes
sinon il y aura quarante mille morts et
la flotte internationale aérienne sotra
paralysant toute l'économie mondiale
banega
tout d'abord mon goût mais porte
également des 120 des tons et vous voici
pour l'amérique du sud edouard côte pour
les usa et le canada
128 mais ça ne sombrait dans les airs
pour l'europe
la slovène de fraude landes francfort
[Musique]
escales fans pour l'asie mais oui ce cas
fans
il revient tout de suite il m'a prié
d'excusés je représente les états unis
le capitaine fils auteur représente la
france
moi je représente l'angleterre et
d'ailleurs je parle sans actifs et vous
vous représenter l'union internationale
des savants ou quelque chose comme ça
les bains je crains bien que ça ne soit
notre première et dernière réunion
je vais grasset moi j'en suis sûr il
faut faire vite la cuisse et une source
vitale de côté qui est doux demande l
empereur nous avons travaillé pendant
dix ans en extrême orient
qu'est ce que vous faites ici j'ai été
envoyé par mon gouvernement pour
neutraliser chandra gore qui est ici
pour organiser la destruction de la
flotte aérienne mondiale
j'ai réussi à entrer dans son système ce
que première fois joué les agents d'où
s'est pas vraiment sortir notre acompte
d'impôt allemand fournir l'occasion
edwin base à l'afrique du sud 17
appareils total 387 ne manque plus que
la cie de l'est ou risque
à escales fans combien voulez vous
assurer de détournement pirates
1 2 3 4 5 et 3 8 et 3 11
que voulez vous dire par là ceux ci
[Musique]
or
force
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
honorable mais selon la règle leurs
rituels et la tradition des ancêtres
nous vous réitérons notre de mort
quelqu'un fait qu'elle est une femme
vous trouve très beau
[Musique]
oui honorable mettre uniquement par
notre esprit notre technique et pour
servir la paix d or
[Musique]
je le répète uniquement par notre esprit
notre technique et pour servir la paix
des hommes
[Musique]
ral ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon le rite je le déclare uniquement
par notre respect notre technique et
pour servir la paix des hommes d'autres
cas des casses est constitué
[Musique]
quand
e
oh
pas
m
[Musique]